Jeep Wrangler key fob programming
differs between JK and JL models. For JK
models from 2007 to 2018, it's a manual
process using ignition cycling and
button presses. For JK models, turn the
ignition from off to on and back to off
within 5 to 10 seconds to enter
programming mode. Then press the fob
buttons. JL models, especially with UK
Connectnect 4 or 5, use the Jeep Wave
smartphone app for remote pairing via
Bluetooth. Download the app, link your
VIN, and scan the FOB's QR code. The key
difference is app integration for JL
owners, offering a modern approach. For
both models, ensure your FOB battery is
fresh and there's no signal
interference. JK owners can use
aftermarket programmable fobs for newer
features. Common issues include dead
batteries and software glitches,
especially in JL models with UK
Connectnect. If you encounter pairing
loops, a dealer software flash might be
necessary. Always check your Jeep's
manual for model specific instructions.
Statistics show that DIY programming
success rates are higher for JK models
at 78% compared to JL models at 65% due
to app complexities. Consider
professional programming for JL models
to avoid potential BCM corruption. For
JK models, ensure all FOBs are present
during programming as they all need to
be programmed at once.
Looking ahead, the trend is towards
digital key management. Expect increased
app-based pairing and potentially
AIdriven keyless entry in future
Wranglers. While traditional FOBs may
decline, cyber security remains a
concern, prompting Jeep to prioritize
encrypted pairing protocols.